all right this is on oracles and alcohol
methods for proving lower balance with
nikhila BS
who was it MIT but is now at Harvard
so this paper
um is really two sub Vapors but both of
them deal with Oracle
um so they are related and they both
have to deal with
um using algorithms to prove a lower
bounds
um and how oracles interact with the two
situations
so the first paper asks questions like
what is the smallest complexity class
continue the function of Maximum circuit
complexity the largest possible which is
about to the end over n
ope and the best one complexity classes
something like
exponential time with a signature P
Oracle okay but that's from like the
1970s and we'd like to know if there's
like smaller classes like
could stigma 2E itself or could any have
a function of Maximum circumflex Theory
um this depending on how small the class
gets because this could have some
interesting consequences
um so to get a handle on this problem
and clean the way uh we Define a generic
finalization problem
okay and it's really simple so it gives
you a list of instance of links n and M
is less than to the N I want you to find
a string on the list okay because in
this lesson to you you're guaranteed
um that at least one string is not in
the list you just want to find one right
and the idea you know is that this is
some generalization diagonization right
so the strings are two tables of easy
functions and our task is to find a
function that's not easy
okay
so variance uh the missing string
problem are well known the literature
and algorithmic puzzles for example
there's a well-known linear time
algorithm for the problem which is
sometimes given in coding interviews
um so we study missing string in two
different ways
so our first main result on this line is
local algorithms for missing strings so
we construct algorithmsing string that
make a few bit probes into the input in
order to determine any output bit and we
use this to obtain a stronger time
hierarchy theorem with advice
right
so we we show how these local algorithms
translate nicely to a new topography
results
okay uh the second main result is uh
well we don't actually resolve like
question one here but we we show some
deep connection uh with the missing
string problem so we show how efficient
uniform circuits for missing strain are
equivalent
uh to the case where some nice
complexity classes have functions of
Maximum circumplexity in a relativizing
way okay
um
so
for example uh depth three uh circuits
of their debt three circuits are missing
string
then uh relative to every Oracle Sigma
2E requires maximum circuit complexity
okay I'll say more about that in detail
in the next slide
so that's the first sub paper okay the
second uh sub paper as does the Arabic
method for circular lower bounds
relative eyes so the average method is a
general framework in which we try to
prove circuit lower balance for explicit
functions by designing arms which
analyze those circuits some interesting
way
and while it was known that the Lord
bounds themselves do not relative eyes
it was possible the connection going
from algorithms to lower bounds good
relies
um so maybe you know just there's some
relativizing way in which you can just
generically translate certain analysis
algorithms and circular balance for
example uh in de-randomization so the
famous connections from lower bounds to
pseudonym generators to relative ice
like just given a circuit lower bound
relative to oracles
you will get pseudogram generators
altitude workers right so it it seemed
possible this this could happen so our
first main result along these lines is
um
no
um the algorithm method because circuit
lower balance does not roll devise in a
particular sense
and our second main results is also no
and this time is in a different color
um so we show two different contexts in
which the algorithm method does not real
devise in a strong way
um this is bad news in some sense uh
right because we it would be more
General and possibly more applicable if
our method could well devised if it
would hold up even when you have
arbitrary oracles on like the circuit
you're analyzing and algorithms you're
using but it just doesn't work out um
see the paper for details
um
I won't talk about it here but you know
if you like oracles
you know you're gonna you're gonna love
it all right
okay
so I'm not going to talk about this
goodbye
right now I'm going to talk about uh
Missing string and things like this
all right
so again this is our question what's the
smallest complexity class containing a
function of Maximum certain complexity
the best known is e to the sigma 2p and
basically in e to the sigma 2p you can
compute the lexical graphically first
truth table that requires a maximum
circumbox okay so you can kind of like
you do some kind of binary search with
the sigma 2p Oracle in order to achieve
that
okay so
um here's a more specific question which
is getting at question one
um it asks does Sigma 2B contain a
function requiring exponential size
circuits okay
um so I first learned this question I
guess from Harry Berman about 15 years
ago I guess but people have been
thinking about it yeah at least since
the 70s
um
so Khan showed already in 1981 that
Sigma 2E does require a super polynomial
size circuits even sub half exponential
circuits whatever that means you can
look at the paper for definition the
point is this is not exponential size
it's it is it's not uh we would like to
have you know really large circuit lower
bounds
um for some function in Sigma 2E
and anything here is that for this
problem we don't even know this
relativization barrier so
we don't even know if there is an oracle
under which Sigma to E
has some essential size circuits um
so we know there's an oracle under which
Sigma 2E has maximum circuit complexity
the Oracle relative to which P equals MP
let's use that but we don't know if
there's an oracle under which Sigma 2B
has you know sub exponential size
circuits like lowish you know not
possible certain Bugsy
um
so so that makes the question like
already like uh an oracle question in
itself like could we even find an oracle
Choice it's true
um what can we do
so yeah it's possible there's a
relativizing proof in fact that Sigma 2E
requires exponential side strings so a
proof that holds up
um
when you stick in arbitrary Oracles in
Sigma 2E in the circuit class so like
it's possible there's a proof using
standard ideas of this circular bound
it's it's still uh open okay so to get a
handle on this we look at this missing
string problem just to recall what it is
given a list of M strings of length in
find a string not on the list okay and
the list is not cannot contain all
possible strings so there's got to be
something on the list
so
um so our main result uh two to iterate
from the previous slide is an
equivalence between missing string
circuits it's like a missing string and
uh the above kind of question okay
so
um in particular so this is just one
instantiation of our main result there
are uniform depth three circuits for
missing string with quasi polynomial
size and poly and bottom fan in on all
lists of uh particularly smaller size if
and only if relative to every Oracle
Sigma 2D requires exponential circuit
complexity almost everywhere this is an
equivalence okay so this question about
or else advising proof what is logo is
equivalent to having uniform depth 3
circuits for missing strain
all right this is It's really
interesting here because all of an ac0
when you get a lower bound you get
something like straight off right you
get like oh I can get this much size
let's use this much depth you know like
with parity majority a lot of stuff but
here here it's it's quite different so
we know that circus of death four exist
okay you can mimic the lexiographic uh
search done by e to the sigma 2p and
find a missing string of that fourth
circuits not difficult to construct
these things exercise for the
um listener uh or viewer of the video
so service does 4 exist
um that two circuits do not exist okay
this roughly corresponds to the fact
that there is an oracle relative which
NX has small circuits so n e has small
circuits relative to some Oracle this
corresponds to there are
um no depth two circuits like say dnfs
for computing a missing string with
these parameters and the fact that depth
four circuits exist uh corresponds to
the fact that there is a relativeizing
proof that say Sigma 3E needs
exponential circumflexity so relative
area Oracle of Sigma 3E uh has a
circular bound and there are depth four
circuits so so this is an interesting
case where like depth three uh is the
real question we want to answer here and
that's the big open problem
um and we don't actually resolve this
question otherwise this paper probably
would have gotten stock box
uh let me know the problem left is
really whether uh Missing string has
that three circuits or not
all right yep so depth three is crucial
here as I already mentioned
okay
so
um now let's talk about the local
elements missing string we're at we're
at the compute a particular bit of the
missing string I just make a small
number of bit probes into the input to
determine like a single bit of the
output okay so that's missing string
again
so I mean we thought of this by a kind
of generalizing the idea behind cancer
it's so Kendra's diagonal argument uh
implies the following okay if the number
of strings in is at most the total
number of bits in then for all I all
possible output bits I we can determine
the ith bit of a missing string with
only one bit probe in the list right we
just take the diagonal we probe the ice
bit of the ice string and we output the
opposite bit right
so this is a diagonal argument right
Okay so
I don't know nomenclature we can say
that there's a one probe algorithm for
missing string when m is the most in the
number of strings at most the total
number of bits in the in the strings
okay so the natural question is what can
we do with K probes okay can how much
can we relax this inequality about M at
most n right this is like some special
case we would like to consider the case
M less than to the n in general but when
m is like sufficiently small we can get
a nice look algorithm okay so what can
you do with K probes
um so so one thing is that it's easy to
get a lower bound right if m is equal to
K times n there's no K minus one program
from this exchange and the idea is that
basically if you have only a k minus one
probe out room so you only use that Q
minus one probes to compute any
particular input bit
there must be some string on your list
you didn't probe at all over all the
possible values of I okay so there must
be something you didn't probe at all
so you know you you can't so whatever
your output that might be on the list
because you didn't actually touch at
least one string on the list
um so okay so
um you can easily get lower bound
and our theorem too is that there's a
there's a pretty close upper bound so if
m is at most uh K times n and there's an
order K log K probiot referencing string
okay
and this is a combination of like
Canada's diagonal argument along with
like some
um sort of uh linear time algorithm for
missing string so it's just a
interesting uh combination of these two
algorithms like uh combining together in
a particular way and this implies for
example
um time Anarchy terms with advice uh for
reasons I'm not going to go into here
you can look at the paper so for example
time
um in the 2C plus one for constant C is
not contained in time into the C with n
plus C log in with the device now the
interesting
um uh thing here is that the advice is
longer than linear so typically when you
prove a Time hierarchy theorem of device
you can really only use in bits of
advice the idea is like you use the
input you're getting itself and like you
pretend it's advice here we can actually
treat advice that's longer than the
input given
um by using this local algorithm for
missing string in a in a nice way right
so there's many other corollaries this
is just one of them uh I'll leave that
there the big open problem here is the
closing gap between the upper and lower
bound right we have this lower bound of
about K we have upper bound of order K
log K what's the right answer for for uh
Missing string algorithms like when the
number of strings is K times n uh what's
the minimum number of probes you need to
compute a missing string
all right so
um
I'll conclude with our main open
problems
those missing string have small uniform
depth three circuits or not uh remember
it cannot have that two circuits even 90
form it does have uniform that three
circuit so four circuits that does have
uniform that Force again
I'm actually not sure which way this
question should go
um
and there's there's other
generalizations of this question like
you can see the paper uh there's a
there's a vast generalization of like
just you know step three whatever ACC or
stuff that's just one special case of
something much more General the paper
um so not in general constructing better
missing string circuits directly
corresponds to getting better
relativizing uh lower bounds
uh the last open problem is how many
probes are necessary and sufficient to
find a missing screen when the number of
strings m is the most K times the number
of bits in the string and
um that's all I got for you
uh thank you very much for paying
attention
hello
welcome to my talk